[Musik]
er ist gewissermaßen das gegenstück zu
den k s p future protesten
das ist hier eben nicht umher sondern
tendenziell weniger unterstützt
der stein des anstoßes ist das agrar
paket auf das landwirtschaftsministerium
über klöckner und umweltministeriums
wenn der schönsten sind tember geeinigt
sieht unter anderem vor dass die
subventionen für landwirte stärker daran
gekoppelten habilitierte für den
umweltschutz tun und auch steuere ich
ein schutzprogramm
das alles passt dem land müssen nicht
gleiches gilt für die dinge voran vielen
regionen deutschlands und seit jahren
trat werkzeug grundwasser zu hoch
gearbeitet deshalb daran die dinge
regeln zu verschärfen
die landwirte halten dagegen sie
fürchten eine unterdrückung ihrer
pflanzen und entsprechende ernst das
alles ist für die cdu ein großes problem
der klöckner versucht zwar immer in die
bauern zu noten wie wichtig sie für die
gesellschaft unverzichtbar sind in
unserem nachwuchs produktion
sicherzustellen
aber zugleich möchte die cdu verstärkt
auch ein großes publikum erreichen
wähler die sonst vielleicht den grünen
ihre stimme geben
gerade in den ländlichen regionen aus
deutschland sind inzwischen viele
landwirte zur übergelaufen
das gefällt den parteistrategen
natürlich gar nicht bislang sind nur
noch zehn prozent der
landwirtschaftlichen fläche in
deutschland wie betriebe bei biofleisch
liegt der marktanteil unter zwei prozent
der wunsch vieler menschen nach einer
ökologischen landwirtschaft der markt
zwar auf der straße bei dem teil des
kunden vor protesten sehr spürbar sein
wenn es um die kaufentscheidung im
supermarkt geht ist das allerdings noch
nicht der fall und auch das ist einer
der punkte den die landwirte hier
kritisiert
[Musik]